Let's go next to our caller from the seven
one nine area code.
Who's calling today from seven one nine.
Hi, David.
Is this me?
Yes it is.
Hey, uh, David, um, so I was hoping to ask
you about a video you've made a couple of
days ago where you were debating which drug
should and should not be legalized.
Yes.
Um, and I guess my main question about that
video is that if we don't completely legalize
all drugs, even cocaine and heroin and things
like that, doesn't that leave the cartels
in a position to still make tens of billions
of dollars every year and subject to the nations
of central and South America to, you know,
their whims and doesn't that leave him in
power?
It does.
I mean, so the best two arguments for legalizing
everything recreationally in my mind are the,
you still have a black market and cartels
wielding a lot of power if something is decriminalized
but still not legalized, uh, and you can control
the production such that, you know, people
are using safe stuff of regulated stuff if
you legalize it.
So yeah, I mean those are, those are the strongest
arguments for legalization.
It's just, it is hard for me with something
that is just as objectively destructive as
heroin or cocaine.
It's hard for me to say this should be a recreational
thing and the way that marijuana or maybe
even some hallucinogenics should be, I'm just
not there yet.
But as I've said before, my position on this
is, is iterating.
Okay.
Awesome.
Well, David, thank you so much for your time
and I gotta tell you, man, you're like one
of my favorite people,
like, you know, in the public type.
Right.
Thank you.
Thank you, David.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much for the call.
And on that note, let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we
will get through more calls right after this